KILMEADE WHO SPOKE ABOUT THE
MENACE OF THAT MACHETE
WIELDING.
THAT AIRS ON "FOX & FRIENDS"
IN THE MORNING EARLY NANCY
PELOSI AND OTHERS HAVE
RALLIED TO THE DEFENSE OF
MS-13.
SADLY OTHER PEOPLE HAVE
LEARNED THE TRUTH ABOUT IT
ROD MICKENS' DAUGHTER WAS
MURDERED BY MS-13.
THANKS FOR COMING ON
TONIGHT.
>> THANKS FOR HAVING ME,
TUCKER.
>> Tucker: WHAT'S YOUR
REACTION TO THE CONTROVERSY
AROUND THE PRESIDENT'S
DESCRIPTION OF MS-13 AS
ANIMALS?
>> HE WAS ACTUALLY BEING
VERY POLITE ABOUT IT.
YOU KNOW, HE CAN'T REALLY
SEA WHAT'S ON HIS MIND
BECAUSE PEOPLE LIKE TO TAKE
THINGS OUT OF CONTEXT.
BUT WHAT THEY DID IS A IS
AADVANTAGE ACT AND HE NAILED
IT ON THE HEAD BY CALLING
THEM ANIMALS.
>> Tucker: WHY DO YOU THINK
PEOPLE WOULD DEFEND THEM?
>> BECAUSE THERE IS ALWAYS
GOING TO BE SOMEBODY WHO IS
GOING TO TAKE SOMETHING THAT
THE PRESIDENT SAYS AND TAKE
IT OUT OF CONTEXT.
THEN BE ON THE OPPOSITE SIDE
OF WHAT THE PRESIDENT IS
TRYING TO DO.
WHICH IS BASICALLY JUST
TRYING TO HELP US, NOT MY
FAMILY BUT HELP US, THE
UNITED STATES.
THE CITIZENS OF THE UNITED
STATES.
WITH THIS PROBLEM WITH THE
MS-13 HOW IT'S RUINING
FAMILIES.
>> Tucker: IT SURE IS.
WE ARE PROBABLY ROUGHLY THE
SAME AGE.
I MEAN, MS-13 DIDN'T EXIST
WHEN YOU WERE A KID.
>> NO, THEY DIDN'T.
I THINK THEY HAVE BEEN
AROUND FOR MAYBE 20 YEARS IN
THE UNITED STATES.
>> Tucker: YEAH.
TELL US WHAT HAPPENED TO
YOUR DAUGHTER.
>> MY DAUGHTER MICKENS WAS
ATTACKED THE EVE OF HER 16TH
BIRTHDAY.
WALKING WITH HER BEST FRIEND
BACK TO KAYLA'S HOUSE AND
THESE VICIOUS ANIMALS
APPROACHED THEM AND DECIDED
TO KILL BOTH OF THEM OVER A
DISPUTE THAT HAPPENED IN
HIGH SCHOOL BETWEEN KAYLA
AND ONE OF THE MEMBERS OF
MS-13.
>> Tucker: HAD NOTHING TO DO
WITH YOUR DAUGHTER?
>> MY DAUGHTER WAS JUST AT
THE WRONG PLACE AT THE WRONG
TIME SHE REALI WAS.
>> Tucker: I'M SORRY ABOUT
THAT.
>> THANK YOU.
>> Tucker: WHAT DID THE
PRESIDENT SAY TO YOU TODAY?
>> HE SAID WE ARE WORKING
HARD.
WE ARE GOING TO CONTINUE
FIGHTING TO ERADICATE THIS
GANG AND AMERICA HAS GIVEN
US NOTHING BUT SUPPORT ABOUT
WHAT HAPPENED TO US AND TO
THE OTHER FAMILIES THAT ALSO
SUFFERED THE SAME WAY
THROUGH THE CRIMES OF THE
MS-13.
HE IS STICKING BEHIND US
100 PERCENT AND SO AM I.